you got like the celebrity beard you
think yeah it's like do you like it
groom somewhere you just like let it
grow no I'm just saying what does it
doesn't look like it's celebrity status
feel weird what you look at my lips for
a second I mean I'm looking all around
our back now looks like you're looking
at me room
do you like you're not I looked I went
to two barbershops today I couldn't find
one person who like actually cooked
facial hair
I can cut facial area you're not gonna
come you know what I when I was doing
the movie premiere stuff the the lady
that was doing all the makeup and
everything would give us a beard oil all
you talk about is the gallows this how
is that get over it yo it is 6 a.m.
hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm ryan
shoes shoes ryan shoes was telling me
about this Viner who i've never seen and
it sounds like he does some really
awesome vines Zach king best vines
compilation 2015 forgot who sent it to
me well it was in your it was in your
inbox stuff yeah sweet
so let's brush the shin stone my
satisfaction photobombing a crying shoot
my shoes how do you do that this is how
I decide may I love Easter candy hmm
what the [ __ ] did I'm so shocked here
and see this real life this extreme gift
wrapping bones how I had my instagrams
so I missing this there we go
petal of the net there bring your pet oh
come on bow kitten back there setting up
my Christmas tree spire
what merry Christmas to you too sir
that's a sweet looking sky today hmm
how's it take you cloud so can fight
this mo is how it seems wait a minute
Zak acute Lord you will be cuter with
curly hair Wow right how do I get to be
on the show nice copying and pasting
money I've seen that one guy a school
invisibility lifeguard dude this kid is
creative is insane I don't
Oh gentlemen wrapping a souvenir from
France
no way
messy buku oh these are stocking
what it's like [ __ ] jumper
I'm rich dinner no way
time to face my greatest fear
the ice bucket challenge you ready Wow
perfect Bravo
worth it right hands down that's the
most impressive vines I've ever seen
yeah totally into that guy as soon as I
started watching his stuff I started
seeing him everywhere McDonalds
commercials Time Warner commercials like
everything this kid I'm so shocked yes
this is way more than just like a joke
in a punchline oh yeah
this is like some of the most creative
yeah intense [ __ ] I've ever saw does he
do all that if no idea should be working
on like [ __ ] huge movies yeah at
first when vine was like really
minimalistic and he came out with that
stuff I was like there's no way you can
do that yeah and then I tried and failed
dude that is one secksy Talent
good gosh man looks good doing it
Veronica might actually have sex with me
if I was able to do that maybe that's a
long shot it's aa long shot yeah like a
long penis like a long mo the Jackie
throne era oh ma shot it's a shot yeah
so oil man and I went way over your head
shot it right off shudder right I'm
trying to build up my vines right now I
was instructed by my representation to
uh Veronica no it's guy named Kyle okay
guys watch Kyle wants me to build a my
Instagram and Vine I have to do that so
I wanted to check out more Viners oh
well this makes me kind of intimidated
to go into the vining game because every
vine I I quit as soon as I started
seeing this guy it's like too good
knowing I can never get up to that level
I'm really selling myself short here
there's got to be a waiting I don't like
that I think that you have the ability
to at least figure out the effects I
don't know I think you got this but
they're soaked their creative tricks -
watch - it's more than just some special
effect it's like no they surprise you I
know I love the story behind all of us
it's great and you never see them coming
I do not eating a peep and then peep
picking out a chick come on some of that
[ __ ] like with the [ __ ] coming
through
television oh great whoa I don't know
I said jumping to jumping through things
I don't understand like jumping through
the car door I guess it's a quick
because it was the subway and I was like
did they actually have to jump through a
tree that's not a boy okay like how did
they do that that is some of the most
impressive [ __ ] dude and Wow thank you
for showing me that my eye had King I
have a few vines up there they're mainly
pooping dick jokes so you enjoy I have
some funny clean ones that are like
cleaner eggs are clean mine but they're
funny well they're not that funny I
thought so I thought so rhyme you solve
it didn't bother no deme you know you
had won some of my videos have a hundred
likes really it's kind of a big deal I
know you guys know Pfeiffer brown and
she has one vine that blew up and at one
point we were competing on like vine
like who could be vine fulness first
mm-hmm she [ __ ] won like she had a
vine that got over a million likes like
she actually did it you know I always
like compete you're like my Instagram
pictures gonna get 200 likes mine is
gonna get 95 cannot compete with women
on a social network I guess that's true
yeah you cannot because they will win
for being hot if you look at any like
social media person even YouTube who's a
woman if they're hot that's most of the
comments thank you you're hot here hot
damn and they talk about how they want
to do like nasty things to them people
talking on my girls you guys want to say
some nasty stuff in my vine I'll take
the likes and take you want to say some
nasty comments about me once in a while
so they're just my girlfriend stop until
you're free sexist man that'd be a piece
of [ __ ] to me being gay not as much of
as soon as you thought I'm gonna troll
your [ __ ] so ain't no thank you
Kyle your bro your boys and be like wow
you've really bumped up your yeah your
comment sections of doing great who's
this one guy anyway guys thanks for
tuning in decisions in the channel if
you want to subscribe you can by
clicking this button above
my head and you could check out Ryan
shoes like we mentioned many times on
this channel from the gallows this and
he's also on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter which social network has the
most following all Facebook probably has
a lot but my instagrams doing okay how
many Facebook Likes do you have total
yeah no I friends wait a minute I don't
have a page you don't have a fanpage no
I have so many friend requests right now
you're telling me the gallows was seen
by millions of people and you don't I
gotta tell you that just social media
thing is like it's great but I just
don't want to do it that's why you're
not booking as much as you want to Wow
old-school tradition of real acting
talent doesn't work anymore it says I'm
ahead of promoters I can't send my black
and white headshots out anymore what
about my VHS style reel that [ __ ] I will
react to on this channel you have like
long hair oh yeah I did
okay maybe we should toss a picture up
there of my long hair days oh that's
what you look like whoa you know when
there's like twins
and then there one twin just happens to
be better than the other twin like
better-looking I'm done you're the
unattractive twin to your modern date so
what happened what happened you got like
incredibly more attractive I was going
to homecoming with a girl named Sarah
Edwards yes Sarah if you're out there
sarva move you missed out